[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und marietas lomka guten Abend
Innenministerin Felser war nach der
Kompromissfindung gestern Abend in
Luxemburg ja noch bester Dinge und
freute sich über eine wie sie sagte
historische Entscheidung dabei wird hier
aber schon geschwant haben dass es
daheim in Berlin Probleme geben könnte
nur die FDP ist voll des Lobes ihre
eigene Partei die SPD auffällig still
und bei den Grünen kracht ist und das
richtig heftig es wirkt fast so als sei
der europäische Asyl Kompromiss der
Tropfen der bei Teilen der Grünen das
fast zum Überlaufen bringt
wie groß der Ärger ist zeigt sich am
Abend
9.40011 Kilometer von Berlin entfernt in
Panama muss die grüne Außenministerin
die eigene Partei Zuordnung rufen
es ist in vielen Bereichen auch ein
bitterer Kompromiss aber ein nötiger
Kompromiss um die unterschiedlichen
Interessen der EU zusammenzubringen und
um den Status Quo der eine erbitterte
Situation an den Außengrenzen ist zu
verbessern dafür und dagegen zugleich
das sind sie bei den Grünen und richtig
wütend bei der Grünen Jugend die Ampel
scheitert gerade an ihren eigenen
Ansprüchen und damit auch an den
Ansprüchen der Grünen und da muss man
glaube ich jetzt drüber sprechen welche
Konsequenzen man ziehen kann die
Parteispitze streitet offen man spricht
hier von Diskurs kein Ausweg in Sicht
ein politischer Eiertanz
dieser Vereinbarung ist
ein Durchbruch weil seit Jahren in der
Europäischen Union auf einer Einigung
gewartet wird aber Durchbruch ist das
nicht es ist es ist ein Durchbruch aber
kein großer Wurf und der Gesamtschau
komme ich zu dem Ergebnis dass wenn es
darum geht auf der einen Seite dem Leid
an den Außengrenzen gerecht zu werden
und auf der anderen Seite mehr Ordnung
in Europa zu schaffen diese Reform nicht
reicht auch in der SPD gibt es
enttäuschte noch aber dominiert das
gestern in Luxemburg gelang was eine
ganze Reihe Innenminister der Union
nicht geschafft hat die vergangenen
Gipfel die Gipfel des Scheiterns waren
gehören der Vergangenheit an insofern
nennt sich Faser und Olaf Scholz etwas
geschafft was in der deutschen
Innenpolitik über viele Jahre ein ganzes
Jahrzehnt nicht möglich war vor dem
Berliner Reichstag sammeln sich am
Nachmittag die Demonstranten
Menschenrechtsorganisationen sie Retter
und auch die Linke
es ist kein historischer Erfolg
Abschottungspolitik betreibt und wenn
man sogar Familien mit Kindern an den
Außengrenzen inhaftieren will das ist
ein Erfolg für die extreme Rechte in
Europa genau entgegengesetzt die Kritik
aus dem Rest der Opposition alles nicht
genug
es ist ein wichtiger wichtiger Schritt
in die richtige Richtung und jetzt
brauchen wir aber noch deutlich mehr
sicherlich gehen einige Forderungen auch
in unsere Richtung aber die EU will
leider Zuwanderungsproblem auch
weiterhin nur verwalten und nicht lösen
entscheidend ist dass Deutschland bei
der Flüchtlingsaufnahme entlastet wird
und das kann ich bisher noch nicht
erkennen ganz im Gegenteil es gibt
keinen verpflichtendes solidarisches
verteilssystem das Deutschland entlastet
Freude und Frust das begleite den
gefundenen Kompromiss am schwersten
damit tun sich die Grünen
aber wollen wir sprechen mit nur dem
grünen Chef guten Abend vor
schönen guten Abend wenn man sich mal
die Stimmen aus ihrer Partei anguckt
ihre co-chefin Ricarda lang da hätte man
nicht zustimmen dürfen die eine der
beiden fraktionschefinnen Frau dröge das
war nicht gut verhandelt oder Anton
Hofreiter eine prominente Stimme riesen
Fehler da ist man eingeknickt für
Populisten wie kriegen sie das denn
jetzt wieder eingefangen und alle noch
mal auf eine Linie
es ist sehr deutlich dass dieses Thema
für uns das Partei unglaublich wichtig
ist und wir haben zusammen gekämpft und
sind zu diesem Ergebnis gekommen und bei
der Bewertung einzelner Maßnahmen sind
wir auch nicht auseinander am
Gesamtpaket gehen die Meinungen wie sie
gesagt haben auseinander und wir haben
darüber nachgedacht ob wir das jetzt
über kleistern und fanden das gehört
sich nicht das Thema ist so wichtig und
deshalb sind wir mit einer großen
Transparenz daran gegangen wir werden
die Debatten die nächsten Wochen
miteinander weiterführen und werden
natürlich darüber sprechen wie genau
umgesetzt wird für was dort vereinbart
worden ist das ist ja schön dass sie
jetzt so in derartigen Krach als
Transparenz verkaufen aber es muss ja
auch irgendwelche Konsequenzen oder
Folgen haben sie müssen ja irgendwie
zueinander finden z.B auch Sie und Ihre
kurschefin
ich kann den versprechen dass wir
sehr sehr eng muss abgestimmt haben wir
haben teilweise wir haben ja auch
sozusagen eine sehr große
Übereinstimmung in der Bewertung dessen
was da passiert ist wir waren uns die
ganze Zeit einig die Situation an den
Außengrenzen ist so nicht haltbar da
gibt es weder Humanität noch Ordnung und
deshalb braucht es diese Verhandlungen
am Ende hätte es aus meiner Sicht dieser
Zustimmung auch bedurft und es war ein
notwendiger Schritt dass Deutschland
dort zugestimmt hat die qualifizierten
Mehrheiten die gab es auch ohne
Deutschland bei dieser Angelegenheit das
heißt dieser Vereinbarung wäre auch
Deutschland ohne Deutschland zu stellen
Sie sich wünschen Frau Ferse hätte dann
nicht zugestimmt
ich glaube dass das notwendig und
richtig war dass Frau Feser zugestimmt
hat Frau veter hat auch nicht alleine
zugestimmt sondern die Bundesregierung
hat dort zugestimmt und
es geht darum dass wir in der
Europäischen Union Vorankommen es gibt
einige Elemente in diesem Gesamtpaket
die sind ein Erfolg dass es jetzt eine
Verbesserung gibt bei Verteilung dass es
jetzt Zugang gibt zu Rechtsberatung das
sind Erfolge wir hätten uns natürlich
andere Ergebnisse gewünscht und jetzt
gilt das dass wir miteinander und in der
Europäischen Union bereit mitwirken dass
die Umsetzung eine ist die besser ist
als so manches was wir dort ließ nun
aber regen sich ja einige ganze Reihe
ihrer Parteifreunde Freundinnen darüber
auf dass eben auch Familien in diese ja
ich sag mal Lager an den Außengrenzen
gebracht werden können da sagt dann Frau
Felser ich habe sie gestern Abend im
heute schon darauf auch angesprochen das
würde eigentlich kaum vorkommen weil die
die es betreibe die meisten nicht als
Familien in der Regel es geht ja um
Asylbewerber die aus Ländern kommen mit
eher geringer Quote und die Familien die
Großfamilien das sind dann eher Syrer
oder Afghanen die Begriffe ist ja nicht
ist das ganze dann vielleicht ein Stück
weit ein Sturm im Wasserglas
ich würde sehr gerne dann wenn es soweit
ist nennt sie Feser auch beim Wort
nehmen wir erleben zurzeit ja an einigen
Orten mit zum Beispiel die Moria das
bereits geltendes Recht ja nicht
eingehalten wird ich habe das Interview
was Sie beschrieben haben auch gesehen
und es war am Klang mir jetzt alles ein
bisschen sehr leicht wie sie es
formuliert hat das ist auch ein langer
Weg dahin und wir werden das sehr sehr
streng anschauen und und begleiten und
auch Aufmerksamkeit erregen wenn wir das
Gefühl haben dass es nicht kommt was
heißt denn das jetzt ernsthaft begleiten
ich meine jetzt ist ja erstmal diese
Einigung da die wollen Sie daran jetzt
noch etwas ändern im Europäischen
Parlament haben die Grünen jetzt auch
nicht diese Mehrheit
es ist richtig dass die Grünen im
Europaparlament nicht die Mehrheit haben
aber das was vereinbart worden ist ist
erstmal eine politische Vereinbarung es
ist nicht geltendes Recht das muss noch
in Richtung Gesetz gegossen werden das
heißt das Europa-Parlament wird auch
eine gewichtige Rolle spielen ich habe
heute den Bundeskanzler so verstanden
dass auch er hofft und glaubt dass im
Europa-Parlament noch einiges verbessert
wird das heißt die Grünen sind mit
diesem Anliegen gar nicht allein es sind
eigentlich auf auch aufgefallen dass man
aus der SPD irgendwie auch nicht so
richtigen Jubel gehört die sind
unheimlich still
es gibt keinen Grund zu jubeln und das
ist kein Thema was nur die Grünen
beschäftigt dass bei uns in Diskussion
so läuft wie sie wie es bei grünen
Tradition ist finde ich zeigt auch wie
stark dieses Thema unserem Herzen liegt
wir haben nicht die Robe diskutiert was
macht das denn eigentlich hier mit der
AFD was macht das denn eigentlich mit
politischen Mehrheiten sondern die
zentrale Frage für uns in der Bewertung
ist was macht das mit den
Schutzsuchenden anderen Außengrenzen
danke für das Gespräch
das Interview haben wir vor einer Stunde
geführt
in den Überschwemmungsgebieten in der
Ukraine ist die Lage weiterhin
katastrophal zumal Retter bei den
Evakuierungsmaßnahmen beschossen werden
dass die Russen den Staudamm gesprengt
haben stellt in der Ukraine niemand in
Frage der ukrainische Geheimdienst sagt
dass er dafür auch Beweise habe und
veröffentlichte eine Aufnahme auf der
einen entsprechendes Gespräch zwischen
zwei russischen Soldaten zu hören sein
soll von allein dürfte der Staudamm
jedenfalls nicht gebrochen sein
norwegische Seismologen sind aufgrund
von Messungen sicher dass es an dem Damm
eine schwere Explosion gab der Wahl wird
dann den Fronten im Süden und Osten der
Ukraine heftig gekämpft Annegret
osterrichtet
Renata ukrainische Soldaten Rücken vor
feuern Gewehrsalven ab
angeblich vertreiben sie den russischen
Feind in der Nähe von saporicia die
Echtheit des twitter-videos kann nicht
mit letzter Sicherheit verifiziert
werden wie so wenig dieser Tage fest
steht nur so viel es wird heftig
gekämpft und beide Seiten reklamieren
die Erfolge für sich einiges spricht
dafür dass die lang angekündigte
Gegenoffensive der Ukraine begonnen hat
wir beobachten erhebliche Verluste der
Truppen des ukrainischen Regimes es ist
bekannt dass bei offensiv Operationen
die Verluste bei etwa 3:1 liegen das ist
eine klassische these in diesem Fall
aber übersteigen die Verluste diese
klassischen Parameter
diese Bilder sollen brennende Leopard 2
Panzer zeigen die westlichen Panzer sind
das modernste Kriegsgerät was die
Ukraine aufbieten kann gegen den
Aggressor immerhin müssen wir davon
ausgehen dass es doch weitaus über 100
Panzer sind die jetzt schon im Einsatz
sind und die Ukrainer setzen Sie ein im
Rahmen eines entscheidenden Schlages und
das bedeutet eine operative gegen
Offensive die konzentriert sich offenbar
auf das Gebiet südlich von saporicia und
donetzka hier könnte die Ukraine einen
Keil in die russische Front treiben und
den Russen so die Verbindung zu der Krim
abschneiden ein äußerst riskantes
Vorhaben von dem viel abhängt in allen
heißesten Gegenden so Präsident selensky
sei ein Kontakt mit den ukrainischen
Einheiten zu den jüngsten kämpfen äußert
er sich nur vage
in der Region dann jetzt gibt es sehr
heftige Kämpfer aber es gibt Ergebnisse
und ich bin jedem einzelnen Kämpfer
dankbar der dazu beigetragen hat bachmut
gut gemacht
für Schritt wir sehen jedes Detail aber
heute ist nicht die Zeit darüber zu
sprechen
die Ukraine scheint wenn nicht alles
dann doch zumindest viel auf eine Karte
zu setzen
wenn es den Ukrainern gelingt in
Korridor tatsächlich zur durchschneiden
aber da steht in den Sternen dann hätten
die Russen ein größeres Problem und das
würde dann schon eine entsprechende
Wende in diesem Krieg bedeuten aber eine
Kriegswende in dem Sinne dass er dann zu
einem Siegfrieden führt die ist
natürlich deswegen noch lange nicht
erreicht der Krieg wird also wohl
weitergehen so oder so
unsere Porter Tim Krüger ist den
saporija und zwar heute auch in Richtung
Front unterwegs Tim was was sind deine
Eindrücke
genau wir sind hier heute Nachmittag von
saporicia in Richtung Süden gefahren in
Richtung Front und waren dann am Ende
ungefähr zehn Kilometer von der Front
entfernt wir waren vor zwei Wochen schon
mal an diesem Ort und unser Eindruck war
heute dass die militärischen Aktivitäten
in dieser Gegend deutlich zugenommen
haben und auch der gefechtslam war
deutlich intensiver zu hören also es ist
ganz klar dass in dieser Region dort
sehr sehr intensiv gekämpft wird und ähm
ja also das war auf jeden Fall schon mal
unsere erste Feststellung und ich denke
halt dass die Situation oder die Frage
ist ob das jetzt die große Offensive ist
im Moment noch nicht beantwortet werden
kann es gibt viele unterschiedliche
Berichte im Moment um diese Lage dort
unten die man nicht überprüfen kann und
deswegen ist es sehr schwer sich dort
ein richtiges Bild zu machen
kannst du uns vielleicht noch mal
erläutern warum jetzt gerade da in der
Oblast saporici also hart gekämpft hat
also warum das für die Ukrainer
strategisch wichtig sein könnte
also diese Region hier sozusagen südlich
von sabricias strategisch deswegen so
wichtig weil die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte von hier aus in Richtung
der Stadt militopol vorstoßen könnten
und dann werden sie praktisch auch schon
am Asowschen Meer und damit hätten sie
dann diesen russischen landkorridor
zwischen Russland und der von Russland
annektierten
Halbinsel Krim durchbrochen und dann
werden im Grunde die Truppen rechts also
westlich von dieser Situation und auch
sozusagen alle russischen Truppen auf
der Halbinsel Krim in einer sehr sehr
schwierigen Situation und ich denke dass
ein solcher militärischer Rückschlag für
Russland aber eigentlich auch für den
russischen Präsidenten Putin persönlich
wirklich eine sehr schwere Niederlage
wäre und auf der anderen Seite wäre ein
solcher militärischer Erfolg natürlich
für die Ukraine sehr wichtig weil sie
damit zeigen könnte dass diese
Milliarden einen westlicher Militärhilfe
die seit Monaten ins Land fließen
wirklich sinnvoll eingesetzt werden also
wenn es wirklich so ist dass dort eine
offensive stattfindet die seitens der
Ukraine in Richtung mehr gehen soll dann
glaube ich sehen wir hier gerade den
Beginn der vielleicht wichtigsten
militärischen Auseinandersetzung in
diesem Krieg eigentlich seit den ersten
Kriegswochen vor mehr als einem Jahr
danke schön Tim für deine Berichte live
aus
aktuelle Videos sind Hintergründe zu
diesem Krieg finden Sie wie immer
natürlich auch online auf ZDF heute und
für den Verlauf dieses Krieges wird auch
entscheidend sein natürlich wer über
welche Waffen verfügt und da scheint es
so dass Russland vor allem mit Iran ein
verlässlichen Lieferanten gefunden hat
mit dem Thema geht es jetzt bei dir
weiterhin ja die USA gehen davon aus
dass Iran Russland nicht nur mit
Angriffs Drohnen beliefert sondern auch
mit Material zum Bau einer eigenen
drohnenfabrik der Sprecher des
nationalen Sicherheitsrates der USA
schon Kirby sagte man habe Informationen
dass diese Fabrik Anfang kommenden
Jahres voll betriebsbereit sein könnte
gebaut wird sie demnach in einer rund
900 km östlich von Moskau gelegenen
Region
nach dem Messerangriff auf Kleinkinder
im französischen an sie hat Präsident
macron das Krankenhaus besucht in dem
drei der vier teils schwer verletzten
Kinder behandelt werden man konnte mit
der Zustand der beiden am schwersten
Verletzten Kinder habe sich stabilisiert
der mutmaßliche Täter wurde
psychologische untersucht sein Motiv ist
weiterhin unklar
der Gründer der Enthüllungsplattform
Wikileaks Julian Assange hat vor einem
britischen Gericht im juristischen
Tauziehen um seine Auslieferung an die
USA erneut eine Niederlage hinnehmen
müssen seine
berufsberufungsanträge wurden am
Londoner high chords abgelehnt die USA
wollen ihn wegen Spionage Vorwürfen vor
Gericht stellen als sonst sitzt seit
2019 in einem Londoner Gefängnis
auf den Philippinen haben die Behörden
wegen eines drohenden Ausbruchs des
Vulkans mahjon mit Evakuierungen in der
Umgebung begonnen aus dem Mahjong steigt
dich der Qualm auf laut der aktuellen
bahnstufe ist ein gefährlicher Ausbruch
innerhalb von Wochen oder sogar Tagen
möglich obwohl Siedlungen rund um den
mahjon nicht erlaubt sind haben viele
ärmere Menschen dort ihre Häuser gebaut
bei den vielen Ermittlungsverfahren die
gegen Donald Trump anhängig sind kann
man ja etwas den Überblick verlieren die
Vorwürfe reichen von Steuerbetrug und
Schweigegeld über sexuellen Missbrauch
weil Manipulationen und Unterstützung
eines Staatsstreichs bis hin zu
Diebstahl geheimer Dokument das ja
geheime Dokumente aus dem Weißen Haus
mit Namen und in seiner Privatvilla in
Florida deponierte soll ihn nun vor
Gericht bringen da steht er dann zwar
nicht zum ersten Mal aber diesmal
handelt es sich um die erste auf
Bundesebene erhobene Anklage gegen einen
ehemaligen US-Präsidenten Claudia Bates
berichtet aus den USA
er ist der geheimnisvollste Mann
Washingtons Jack Smith der
Sonderermittler monatelang hat er
geschwiegen hinter verschlossenen Türen
die Untersuchungen geführt jetzt die
historische Anklage
unsere Gesetze die Informationen zur
nationalen Verteidigung schützen sind
entscheidend für die Sicherheit der
Vereinigten Staaten und Sie müssen
durchgesetzt werden die Gesetze in
diesem Land gelten für jeden
kistenweise waren am Ende von Trumps
Amtszeit Unterlagen aus dem Weißen Haus
geschafft worden nicht zu den
nationalarchiven sondern auf Trumps
Anwesenden Florida er habe sie teilweise
selber gepackt so die Anklage er habe
vorsätzlich geheime Informationen zur
nationalen Verteidigung einbehalten zu
Kriegswaffen zu atomprogrammen habe
Dokumente im Schlafzimmer versteckt im
Bad im Ballsaal der Ex-Präsident
stilisiert sich zum Opfer eines Krieges
der Demokraten gegen ihn
sie versuchen unseren Ruf zu zerstören
damit sie die Wahl gewinnen können
und die Republikaner folgen ihm ronde
Säntis ebenfalls Anwärter auf die
Präsidentschaft spricht vom Einsatz
bundesstaatlicher
Strafverfolgungsbehörden als Waffe
tatsächlich aber war Donald Trump
mehrfach aufgefordert worden die
Unterlagen zurückzugeben und weigerte
sich er spielte mit den Behörden Katz
und Maus einige Dokumente wurden dem
National Archiv ausgehändigt dass seien
jetzt alle hieß es falsch bei einer
Durchsuchung hat das FBI dann 11.000
Dokumente gefunden zum Teil streng
geheime Unterlagen doch Trump bestritt
dass sie geheim waren auf wundersame
Weise habe er die Geheimhaltung
aufgehoben
als Präsident kann man das tun indem man
sagt es ist ein klassifiziert sogar
indem man es nur denkt
ein heimlicher Audio Mitschnitt belegt
dass er es besser wusste bei einem
Treffen mit anderen wurde laut
Medienberichten über geheime Dokumente
gesprochen und Trump sagte als Präsident
hätte ich die Papiere freigeben können
jetzt kann ich es nicht selbst sein
früherer Justizminister kritisiert ihn
deutlich
mit der Zeit werden die Leute sehen dass
dies keine Hexenjagd ist tatsächlich ist
das Justizministerium sehr respektvoll
vorgegangen wenn Trump die Unterlagen
einfach zurückgegeben hätte wäre die
Sache beendet gewesen
trotz der Anklage bleibt Trump der
Favorit für die republikanische
Präsidentschaftskandidatur er kann
weiter kandidieren und auch Präsident
werden selbst bei einer Verurteilung
unter den Nachrichten gehen wir zurück
noch mal nach Deutschland mit dem Thema
Energiepreise ja nach den Strom und
Gaspreis Schocks des vergangenen Jahres
hat sich die Lage für Haushaltskunden
wieder verbessert Energie ist wieder
günstiger zu haben allerdings Frank
Bethmann gilt das nicht für alles und
jeden ja das stimmt für Neukunden sind
Preise zuletzt kontinuierlich gefallen
für Bestandskunden und wer
zwischenzeitlich in die Grundversorgung
gerutscht ist für die sieht es anders
aus hier sagen verschiedene
Energieexperten da sind die Preise nur
wenig gesunken liegen teilweise immer
noch über der geltenden Begrenzung für
höhere Preise gilt die Differenz bezahlt
weitestgehend der Staat beim Strom liegt
die Preisbremse für die Kilowattstunde
bei 40 Cent für Neukunden aber gibt es
inzwischen wieder aktuelle Angebote von
unter 30 Cent wohin gegen Bestandskunden
hier in der Grundversorgung nach wie vor
über 40 Cent zahlen müssen ganz ähnlich
verhält es sich bei den Gastarifen
neukunden profitieren von den gesunkenen
Großhandelspreisen die anderen in der
Tendenz eher weniger einige Versorger
geben die fallenden Preise schneller an
ihre Kunden weiter als andere und woran
liegt das ja das hängt ganz stark von
den Verträgen der Energieversorger ab
mit wie viel Vorlauf sie sich eindecken
in der Regel längerfristig um sich gegen
extreme Preisschwankungen abzusichern
das hat aber zur Folge dass manch einen
Versorger von den aktuell niedrigen
Großhandelspreisen noch gar nicht
profitiert ergo auch noch nicht die
Preise für seine Kunden senkt einen
Anbieterwechsel kann sich lohnen sagen
die Verbraucherzentralen Frank Wittmann
vielen Dank
zum Sport Alexanders wäre es hat bei den
French Open in Paris das Halbfinale
gegen den Norweger Kasper Rüth verloren
den präzisen Schlägen des Weltranglisten
vierten hatte es wäre es wenig
entgegenzusetzen es wäre von der lag
deutlich in drei Sätzen 3 zu 6 4 6 0 6
im Finale am Sonntag trifft auf den
Serben Nowak Djokovic
der deutsche Zehnkämpfer Leo Neugebauer
hat den seit 39 Jahren bestehenden
deutschen Rekord im Zehnkampf geknackt
bei den amerikanischen
college-meisterschaften in Osten Texas
verbesserte Neugebauer die Bestmarke von
Jürgen hingsen um vier Punkte auf
8.836 Punkte und steigerte seine
persönliche Bestleistung um 358 Zähler
[Applaus]
morgen abend um diese Zeit läuft das
Finale in der Fußball Champions League
zwischen Manchester City und Inter
Mailand das ZDF berichtet live ab 20 Uhr
als Favorit in diesem Endspiel in
Istanbul gilt Manchester City
sie sind das Team der Stunde Mitspielern
wie early Holland dem deutschen
Nationalspieler und Kapitän Ilkay
ogane Clara Favorit Manchester City das
Team von Trainer pep Guardiola setzte
sich gegen Top-Clubs wie Dortmund und
Real Madrid durch und jetzt ja will sich
einfach das Gefühl dass man auch auch
dran ist und auch endlich diese Trophäe
Gewinne die berühmte außen seit der
Chance ist jedoch immer da auch Inter
Mailand träumt vom Champions League mit
dem deutschen Robin Inter besiegte
Barcelona den AC Mailand sie sind in
Bestbesetzung seit April ungeschlagen
und das wollen sie auch bleiben
vor 300 Jahren trat in Leipzig ein neuer
Thomas Kantor seinen Dienst an also der
Chorleiter und musikalisch
Verantwortliche in der Thomaskirche das
war schon damals seinen
traditionsreicher Job die Leipziger
Ratsherren hatten eigentlich gehofft den
prominenten Georg Philipp Telemann
abwerben zu können der Liebhaber in
Hamburg
so wurde es dann schließlich ein damals
noch weniger glanzvoller Name Johann
Sebastian Bach ein Tief frommer
38-jähriger Komponist und Kapellmeister
mit großer Familie und Geld Sorgen was
für ein unfassbar kreatives und
produktives Genie er war hat seine
Umwelt damals noch nicht erkannt aber
vielleicht wusste er selbst tief im
Inneren wie absolut zeitlos seine Musik
ist Stefan Kelch
seit dem Vormittag hat die Leipziger
Familie der Bach Jana ein neues und
prominentes Mitglied der Pianist lang
lang ist glühender Bach Verehrer seit
seiner Kindheit
[Musik]
war einer meiner ersten Komponisten eine
der heiligsten Personen die ich auf der
Erde kenne ist Bach
[Musik]
er berührt nicht nur dein Herz auch
deine Seele er ist so einzigartig dass
niemand ihn je ersetzen kann
vor 300 Jahren kam Johann Sebastian Bach
nach Leipzig wurde Thomas Kantor
komponierte im Akkord inzwischen feiern
sie das ganz groß also beginnt sie vor
300 Jahren die Liebesgeschichte zwischen
Leipzig und dem Komponisten aber nein
Fans hat er zu seiner Zeit kaum
Musik sein Duisdorf kompliziert Schwulst
dich wieder die Natur unter den vielen
stimmen würde man keine Hauptstimme
erkennen und so weiter und deswegen
glaube ich tatsächlich dass damals
wahrscheinlich die Leute
eher erstaunt verwundert manche
vielleicht sogar geschockt gewesen sind
gerade die Musiker die das alles so
aufführen mussten die Thomaner damals
die von Woche zu Woche ein neues eine
neue Kantate bekommen haben ein paar
Jahrhunderte später allerdings hat
Leipzig seinen Komponisten so fest ins
Herz geschlossen das ist sogar
derartiges gab
schräge Töne es sind die Töne B a c h
der einst Erkennungsmelodie des
Leipziger stadtfunks
Bach ist universell er passt in alle
Zeiten jeder will ihn vereinnahmen man
hat über Jahrhunderte immer wieder
versucht Bach sozusagen ins eigene Lager
zu holen obwohl der einen sperriger
geistlicher Komponist eigentlich ein
Europäer der Musik ist mit italienischen
Einflüssen französischen Stil man hat
ihn eben insbesondere im 19 und 20
Jahrhundert in der Epoche des
Nationalsozialismus zu einem deutschen
Künstler Bürsten wollen aber Bach gehört
nun einmal niemandem oder besser er
gehört allen
man muss so ein Orgelwerk von Bach gar
nicht unbedingt auf der Orgel aufführen
es wurde schon oft genug demonstriert
man kann diese Werke für große
Sinfonieorchester orchestrieren und es
klingt trotzdem völlig überzeugend man
kann die am Ende auf kennen blasen und
immer noch wird sie so stark wirken weil
einfach die Substanz so verdammt gut ist
und so lässt sie sich trefflich in jedem
musikalische Zukunft eingeben taugt
bestens auch für Klangexperimente
bei Bach ist es immer so dass am Ende
irgendwas ist was eine abstrakte Größe
ist die über die Jahrhunderte hinweg
immer gültig ist ich glaube das ist so
ein bisschen das warum Leute da so drauf
abfahren
zur Stunde passiert genau das auf dem
Markt zu Leipzig sie sollen dieser
Jahrhunderte alten Musik Tribut Bach 300
ach for future
[Musik]
das war es von uns weiter geht's gleich
mit einem heute-show
spezialupdate mit Christopher Wehrmann
und wir melden uns morgen wieder in der
Halbzeit vom Champions League Finale bis
dahin auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend eine Zeit lang saß so aus
als ob dieses Tief tatsächlich mal nach
Osten ziehen würde das hätte dann bei
uns wechselhaft das Wetter gebracht aber
bis Montagabend ändert sich an der
Wetterlage nichts wir haben es nach wie
vor mit einem hoch zu tun und mit einer
ostströmung am Boden heute Nacht sinken
die Temperaturen an der Mosel und am
Rhein kaum unter 17 bis 16 Grad sonst
werden 14 bis 10 Grad erreicht am Küsten
wird es am Alpenrand mit 9 Grad dazu ist
es meist klar und der Tag morgen beginnt
erstmal mit viel Sonnenschein dann
entwickeln sich einige Quellwolken und
vielleicht reicht es an der Elbe auch im
Erzgebirge vielleicht auch im
Oberpfälzer und Bayerischen Wald am
Alpenrand und dem Schwarzwald für
einzelne Regenschauer und Gewitter der
Winter kommt das östlichen Richtungen
und so liegen die Höchsttemperaturen
morgen an der Ostseeküste bei 21 bis 23
Grad sonst werden 23 bis 29 Grad
erreicht am Rhein und lässt sich davon
sind es 30 bis 32 Grad am Sonntag
beschränken sich die Gewitter auf den
Alpenrand bei 23 bis 31 Grad und die
Waldbrandgefahr bleibt sehr hoch nicht
nur im Nordosten und in Niedersachsen
sondern auch im Südwesten an diesem
Wetter ändert sich auch Anfang der Woche
wenig Dienstag und Mittwoch wird es dann
von Osten ein bisschen unbeständiger und
was Sie für ein badewetterwochenende
jetzt noch brauchen sind
Wassertemperaturen die liegen meist bei
17 bis 23 Grad nur die Nordsee ist zur
Zeit noch deutlich kälter schönes
Wochenende